foolish is right go on
furious and you don't believe in enough
to monitor if you don't believe in
heaven and hell and all that why don't
you just go around raping and murdering
as much as you want I do what I do go
around raping and murdering as much as I
want which is not at all
because he's got a conscience what if
death is just the end what's the point
what's the point in war living matters
won't just kill yourself so if you're
watching a movie and you're really
enjoying it somewhat that Kevin Hine and
someone points out that this will end
eventually you just go oh forget it then
what's the point and just turn it off no
cuz I can watch it again well I think
life is precious cuz you can't watch it
again I mean you can believe in an
afterlife if that makes you feel better
doesn't mean it's true but once you
realize you're not gonna be around
forever I think that's what makes life
so magical
one day you'll eat your last meal smell
your last flower hug your friend for the
very last time you might not know it's
the last time so that's why you should
do everything you love with passion you
know treasure the few years you've got
because that's all there is
I watched ride along to five times will
you haven't wasted your life then
definitely not no love Kevin Hart
everything about it
humor its comedy films comedy films
mainly no Liam yeah whatever gets you
through well thanks for coming over
which I imagine I will
I don't imagine it I just know I'm gonna
have to I want to die like my father my
father died [__] he didn't man he was
57 woman was 18 he came and went at the
same time
didn't nobody cried his muna everybody's
a lucky [__] and nobody else
would [__] the woman for two years
either no I don't want none of that
[__] thing and you know I notice
there's a difference in funerals like
white people have funerals they love
they dearly departed but the funerals be
different they don't give it up easy
you know they hold that [__] in till
they get home maybe they go they faint
they get it a few black people let it
hang out then they fall on your ass they
don't never faint it is lean on us
Karam to the conscious it begs me to up
yeah you got to kill me goes that
[__] dead I think actually
scientists should kind of look into that
whole death thing because they seem to
focus on diseases and I'm gonna fight
with him cuz you know the guy go hey you
got a fixed your idea something I'm
still gonna die I think I yeah so that I
think is the biggest problem that's why
I can't get behind politicians you know
cuz they're always like our biggest
problem today is unemployment and I'm
like what about getting old and sick and
dying and they assure me out the back
way you know but seriously if there was
a politician ever that said by my second
term there will be no death I go I vote
very [__] I think I just give that guy
all my money and I'd sit on a chair
sometimes I actually think I won't die
you ever think that you go [__] it I'm
not dying but in your mind when you know
you've analyzed you realize you know
like like I might you know my dad died
and my grandfather died and my
great-grandfather died and you know and
the guy before him I don't know probably
I think he died because otherwise he'd
be on extra know all right I come from a
long line of death that's my point
that's my point
and so I fear it you know I fear it a
lot and I think most of us do you know
it's funny like how like what we fear
how we're gonna die it's always the ways
we don't die you know I mean like we go
goddamn I hope Polar Bear doesn't eat me
there's some crazy [__] you know all
right hope airplane you know I got an
airplane today you know every time you
get out of an airplane you go hope I
don't die but you never die in an
airplane ridiculous
there you go I hope a terrorist does not
attack and kill me I hope that doesn't
happen you know I was afraid of that
but you think about what's the odds that
a terrorist will attack and kill you you
know I almost zero you know but what are
the odds that you will be attacked and
killed by your own heart a hundred
percent you know that hurts not good
people think it is but in people like
heart so here's a Valentine's a heart oh
that guy's got a big heart I leave
better [__] watch it Dan cuz
an attack and kill him I don't know if
he knows that that's what got my dad is
hurt attacked and killed him
and he was lying on his bed and boom
dead on the floor you know as they says
instantly and my dad he wasn't expecting
he was looking for a bug an air of the
[__] and his heart attack to kill them
and was dead like instantaneously
and sad we were all sad when something
like that happens people just try to
make you feel better they'll saying you
know one guy said to me don't worry Nora
he died in his sleep he didn't feel a
thing as I really went his hurt attacked
and killed him he didn't is that wake up
like if my cat walks across my belly
I don't know if my dad was that sound
asleep
one guy said he's in a better place I
said he's on the floor dead earlier he
was alive on the bed that tempur-pedic
pillow I bought him for Christmas I
I'm no physician but I think that's the
better place over there
do you give much thought to that stuff
to the afterlife to God the I did exist
in sir do you just sort of not as much
as I used to I I don't know if it's
arrogance or whatever but I just I once
I was able to kind of wrap my head
around that religions are all based in
the same just natural feeling you have
that if you do something good you feel
good if you do something bad you feel
bad that moral compass thing then once I
just kind of looked how they stay just
sort of exploit all of it and it's
hypocritical and you know just a whole
that you know people who get super
religious like there's people who get so
religious that they commit murder
because somebody says something bad
against their religion and the fact that
they can still think that they're going
to be in the eyes of this higher power
as something good is it's frightening I
think what religion does either
deliberately or inadvertently is it
perverts the your moral compass of doing
good things make you feel good doing bad
things makes you feel bad and like look
believe me dude if I you know when I die
if I am gonna get judged I am NOT gonna
make it I have done some horrible
horrible things and I would literally I
don't what I would have to do I would
have to save a city single-handedly from
a fire while suffering you know
third-degree burns just to get I think
back to even I'm like that like gambler
that's just like I'm just down forever
and I should just walk away I'm never
gonna get even I'm not even gonna get
close so you know I was a piece of [__]
for too long so there you go that's
uplifting what about what if the what if
God is not tied to religion them what
I'm saying is God there's a creator he
makes beings he puts them here and then
that's it hands off that's how I view
him that's how I view him like I don't
view like you you can't sit there and
make seven billion of something give
them freedom of choice and not think
that some sort of chaos is going to
ensue
I think Carlin or somebody said
something about how it's just his
entertainment you
made these things to watch I feel like
you believe that something made us a
creator made us it's not just randomness
no IIIi my honesty's I don't know what
happened I have no idea what happened
but I am more likely to go I go we'll go
70% science 30% philosophy at 0%
religion is how I do it but I like the
ground floor of every religion where
it's like you know you know don't kill
people honor your parents don't steal
and that type of thing although I've
broken a lot of Commandments
[Music]
what do you think happens when we die
Keanu Reeves I know that the ones who
love us misses
[Music]
[Applause]